1 daniel moreau est désormais bon à est
ce qu'elle a fait le bon choix daniel
moreau a pris tous les risques pour
pouvoir peut-être se faire bouillage
mi-juillet
alors ses coûts daniel moreau at elle
pris la bonne décision circuit seul vous
et vous seul pourrait nous le dire dans
un instant sachez que daniel moreau a
passé toute l'après midi chez le
coiffeur ah ouais et elle a toutes tous
blonds non doublons mais doit tout va ou
non de la du sol au plafond à l'hommage
aux disparus de carlus non mais je vous
dis allez du sol au plafond ah oui même
la
jolie a même la salle de jeu vers salle
de jeux wii
[Applaudissements]
elmo et blonde à avoir des sols
en bois vous êtes d'abord pensé un
instant qu est ce que tu es sans emploi
sont
allés boire énormément ivonne baki a
gelé vue
je l'examiné personnes lors de la finale
mais non
marchand pour vous dire j'ai pour mon
dire qualifier encore assuré vraiment du
sol au plafond leblond uma si peu trop
rêver quand même très très bien dans un
instant n'allez pas voir une belle femme
ouais vous allez voir une bombe atomique
daniel mon bébé the wham au bras de ses
coûts
oui c'est une bonne chose d'être prêt en
technique pour s'acheminer que vous avez
fait blond platine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et pour ta gouverne on a fait ce qu'on
appelle un blanc titeuf
quand on a pu s'abaisser pour juste ou
non
on va l'accueillir daniel mots et des
balais jimenez mais comme à sa foi on
dirait qu'elle va voir mon frère owen
sisk perso
c'est parti c'est aller
j'adore
bonjour à tous
sur la tête de ma mère on dirait
catherine deneuve
n'ont
pas fait les racines ben on en fait
c'est un balayage en
fait c'était mon souhait en version
descendre et j'ai un peu comme il ya une
personne qui se dit qu'est ce que je
fous là
[Applaudissements]
cette personne sait c'est qu'on est
jeune et qu'est ce que je fous là sans
déconner non pas vraiment mon succès
merci est ce que tu es heureuse
c'est pas encore ça tire et robert
redford
tu me regarde dans la glace je me
reconnais même pas serré la vallée
comptant alors par contre que le dis
ouais quand on est blanc comme ça faut
vraiment que tu prennes le soleil demain
et après demain pour le tu vas aller
chez quelqu'un qui a une terrasse chez
vous
à une paire à celle un parc arboré col
[Applaudissements]
en v servais parce que au fond quito
c'est en tout les blonds il faut un
gagnant oui je te dis là c'est beau
c'est là tu vas tu mets incroyable tu
vois ça tu étais très bien cette écoute
moi bien je te le dire je te jure il va
y avoir plus de visites dans ta culotte
comme mont saint michel
[Rires]
à ces mots c'est cool d'avoir été la
montée de ses coûts ses coûts est-ce que
tu as quelque chose à dire à ton ex
aminata kenobi
l'état vas-y j'ai fait une bonne affaire
merci non c'est tout d'abord la mauvaise
histoire à laquelle est belle sans
rigoler on dirait on dirait margot
robbie ouais c'est un an mais si on
dirait margot robbie dans quel film un
film d'époque en sortir
[Applaudissements]
tant avec des montants sans du bordel de
merde et lumineuse elle est maquillée à
les méchins daniel jeter genre alors là
je mets au défi franchement quelqu'un de
dire que daniel ni moins séduisante je
me doutais dit celui qui pense pas ça
ils m'appellent tout de suite attendez
j'en appelle
non mais vraiment non mais sans déconner
alors mais je vous le dis et je connais
je connais la gente féminine c'est vrai
je m'en suis éloignée mais je la connais
je la connais attends tu connais
allouagne et non c'est pas parce qu'on
s'éloigne de quelque chose qu'on va vers
autre chose là bas oui voilà il est vrai
que vous avez l'autoroute conseil
bouffer le cul sur le périph
problème quelque part bah oui non et
baron h au milieu du gué c'est pas clair
ce mot dit non mais là il est un gars de
rbo à la lumière de repos quand vous
voyez daniel vous pensez que vous allez
tenir deux ans encore quoi ce que dans
prison
pour deux ans les magnifiques damiette
et heureuse ouais bah oui puis surtout
je viens de voir quoi vous avez
un peu exhibitionniste s'est pas
beaucoup quand même c'est bon ça lui
même alors ces derniers peuvent les
poils on va faire avec le chat
[Applaudissements]